i asked this former hedge fund manager
to share the secrets of the stock market
with us because i sure don't know what
the hell i'm doing he's a finance
professor he's got multiple books on the
subject and he's a youtuber welcome
patrick boyle hi how are you doing good
now listen it's obvious these are dark
times inflation is reaching all-time
highs a new variance is here global
supply issues are here so i want you to
shoot straight with me does anybody know
what's going on it's a it's a tough
environment but you know the truth in
markets is that it's always tough like
there's there's this idea that there's
certain times when everyone knew exactly
what was coming but of course when you
think that something else surprises you
okay okay listen here
i'm against everyone knows i'm against
giving financial advice to my viewers so
we're just going to turn off the cameras
for a second
and i'm just going to ask you
yes or no
should i buy gamestop because i'm all
the kids are into it honestly the 10
million studio it's rough on the bank
account you know rent's very high i need
a little windfall okay as you know i'm
doing this giveaway i i need the cash
flow is gamestop a goodbye right now i
don't like to use the term to the moon
that often but
you know all jokes aside i i wouldn't
touch it like i i just think that
there's
it's a it's all risk and rather
questionable return to me
okay let's hit the hard questions here
uh patrick patrick
uh omicron it's here the the avengers
the transformers in game is here now do
you mean omicron the uh the virus or the
yes the virus oh yes
oh yeah yeah i know we're gonna get to
the crypto don't worry
listen we don't know how bad it is but
should we be should i take my money out
of the market what should i do here you
know i don't think so because in truth
we're we're sort of prepared for viruses
or the idea is there and actually the
world knows how to deal with it much
better than they did a year and a half
ago when the first version of covet came
and in truth i i don't think it's it's
worth panicking in terms of investing
because what i've seen in the past with
investors is often they'll panic when
you know a bad piece of news comes out
and they'll pull all of their money out
of the market and we'll say even if
they're right and the market falls they
never buy on the low they always think
it's going lower and so then it's kind
of five years later and they buy at a
new high you know so unless you really
have a plan for how you're going to get
back in i think if you're invested and
if you're investing for the long term
just stick with your plan yeah that's
very true uh if if you look at my
portfolio i think the honest truth is
i've been probably buying i and uh
selling law
it's actually the biggest problem for
investors there's a really interesting
guy jack schwager i actually i
interviewed him on my channel about a
year ago and he's studied kind of how
investors behave and one of the really
interesting things he found was that
even with some of the best performing
funds like the highest return lowest
risk funds he's found that people invest
in them always after they've done well
and then on any little sell-off they
take their money out so the average
investor in the fund doesn't actually
get the return off the fund and so in
effect once you're aware that people do
that you you can possibly see some of
that in yourself and you just have to
adjust your behavior to sort of not make
the the mistakes that we're almost
programmed to make in markets yeah guys
look it's easy just just buy low sell
high it's just that
it's that simple uh no that is that is
very interesting now i do want to ask
because
as much as kind of we kid it it does
seem like we are in an interesting time
especially with how the fed has been
acting and where the stock market is
and i want to ask you about inflation
okay so
everyone heard the headlines we had like
six percent inflation in october or an
annualized inflation and i get the
basics like you print more money more
money's in the big pool your money's
worth less that's not exactly how it
works i i think
can you explain for someone like me just
a sort of a novice with this stuff
how inflation works
well the truth is inflation just is
complicated like if you're confused by
it it means that you're you're thinking
about it you know and so there there are
many things that are coming together to
cause inflation you know so we have the
simple idea of sort of extra money being
printed that makes very logical sense
that sort of the more you print the less
it's worth but interestingly enough
there's some sort of complicated things
relating to the supply of money where
often that money's getting printed and
essentially it just sits in bank vaults
it doesn't actually go out to people and
so actually the supply of money in the
market hasn't really grown as much as
the supply of printed money which is
kind of interesting
but what what we are seeing at the
moment there's a few things there appear
to be big energy problems in the world
that relate to basically all of the oil
wells and whatever being shut off uh
a year and a half ago and then
essentially they haven't turned them
back on because there's two reasons one
is just that that it's difficult to sort
of turn an oil well back on if you're
not sure that the oil price will remain
steadily high and the second thing is
there's just been quite a strong uh
green push over the last 12 months where
a lot of governments are essentially
saying that they don't want the oil to
come out of the ground which then makes
the oil companies choose to leave it in
the ground
then we also have the supply chain
disruptions and they are you know
hopefully a lot of people understand
them but it's even
that what happened what we're seeing in
inflation is actually inflation in goods
much more than inflation and services
because when people got locked down they
had money coming in and they spent it on
stuff rather than eating at restaurants
or going out on experiences and so you
end up with a huge amount of we'll say
just everyone bought extra extra
computer equipment for home uh cameras
all sorts of things uh which drove up
the price of those uh there was the the
computer chip shortages there's even
just the shipping problems in moving
stuff from you know a lot of the stuff
is made in china and shipped over here
and all of those ports are having
problems there's all these backlogs and
so a lot of the inflation we're seeing
is really just
money chasing goods that aren't being
made like it's you know if you look at
the price of used cars right now they've
rocketed but equally they they were
impossible to to sell uh you know a year
ago in the depths of the lockdown so
it's it's really the the effect of sort
of shutting down and reopening an
economy has caused these problems and
then when we look at a a new variant
that could possibly make do it all over
again it's it's really uh interesting to
see what would happen but inflation is
kind of coming at us from multiple
directions uh it's
it's a great oversimplification to just
say it's printing money that's caused it
well yeah and yeah exactly and that's
what i try to avoid is these
oversimplifications but i'm just sort of
not smart enough smart enough to really
get my hands around it i just put put
all my trust in jay powell basically um
which i'm not sure is the best idea but
but am i cynical for thinking and just
in general that we are overdue for some
sort of correction because let me
explain my thinking on this like it
seems like okay if you go into a
doctor's office and you you somebody
slammed uh a hammer on your hand your
hands all mangled and the person is not
reacting the hand is not hurt yet
there's something wrong with the
situation okay
you're gonna go oh you'll feel that
tomorrow whatever in the same way i feel
like the stock mark or the economy got
like hammered by the by the virus and
then the stock market did not reflect
what had happened to the economy and
it's sort of it i feel like it hasn't
reflected that maybe you can explain
differently but am i cynical for just
like waiting for us to feel the pain
it's a funny thing because if we look
back a year the the market actually
reacted
very rationally because you know if you
remember january through march of 2020
the the market sold off horrifically
like it was just down down down and then
essentially like the the global
governments just came out and said it
doesn't make sense for all of these
we'll say good well-run businesses to
just be shut down because of a random
event that happened and so they
intervened in the markets essentially
saying that if you're running a bit like
if you owned a restaurant they say to
you we're not going to have your
restaurant go bust but equally you can't
open the restaurant and so and all
businesses got that you know ppp and
other type uh
it was a global thing but what it meant
was that that you could invest in stocks
and in companies with the idea that they
won't at least in the short term shut
down because of covert so then it became
that you just looked at the long term
earnings you essentially looked through
the whole covet event towards the the
bounce back you know and now i guess
we're we're in the bounce back and the
question is have things gotten too
fraughty like do
there's always this problem in markets
where if if investors don't ever sort of
get punished for bad behavior for sort
of taking inappropriate risk they do
more bad behavior take more risk right
and so that's kind of what what we're
possibly seeing is that not only have
investors kind of decided that that
there's no way they can lose money but
they've also decided that the craziest
bets are the best bets you know because
if risk doesn't exist well then you just
shoot for return while normally you're
trying to balance risk in return
so okay
let me ask you this it seems like every
18 year old with a
100 bucks from their mom can invest
easier than ever
um but my question is do you think we're
actually doing a good job of training
these new investors to like think
and like we're giving retail investors
sometimes like the power of what you
might used to give to like an
institution
but
are we training them to actually wield
that like like as someone who's taught
students what do you think is it like
feels like we're giving everyone like f1
cars like you know 100x leverage you
know these things that can like
completely wreck you
uh and then just telling them oh yeah go
ahead like
there is that thing in in that you know
especially new investors they they sort
of like i you know i started out
investing in the dot-com bubble in the
late 90s and it was a very similar thing
back then where it was almost like the
crazier the company and the wilder the
claims the more it went up you know so a
lot of people my age kind of piled into
all these crazy stocks and everyone said
this is madness but you know these guys
were making 100 return in a week you
know and it looked great for a while and
then the problem is that you know
reality uh
reappeared and you know that that kind
of has to happen with everything you
know like the
the and a lot of people they all think
they'll know when to get out and the
problem is that that you don't really in
fact i have a finance professor friend
who i was talking to a while ago and he
kind of loves the idea of investing in
tesla but it always looks too expensive
to him because he kind of you know
analyzes it and he he managed to buy
tesla a few years ago you know and it
instantly it kind of doubled and he and
it once again it was too expensive so he
sold it and of course it went up 10
times since then and the problem is you
know like when you get in and out of
these things like you know how do you
get back in again you know and and he
actually i i like his point of view he
says he doesn't feel bad about it at all
because he has a system and he follows
the system and yes if he broke the
system on tesla he'd have way more money
but if he broke it on everything else he
would have lost all of his money so
yeah do you so in that way do you think
it's much more
uh you'll be much more successful if you
just have a system and you stick with
your system and don't like basically
take short-term lessons from things like
tesla which seem like they're very hard
to predict well that that's kind of my
belief is that well it's just because my
approach to investing is essentially
like a a back testing approach where i
just download a load of data and work
out how prices have moved in the past
and try and try and invest based upon
that and so
you know i'm of course going to tell you
that that's the best way of doing things
because that's how i do things but it
seems to me that if you if you can come
up with a good system with like good
reasons i even say to a lot of people
even if you're not kind of a quant
investor i i feel that if you buy
something write down like just get a
notepad write down why you bought it and
when you'll sell it like what how much
it will have to fall for you to sell it
or admit you were wrong and if it goes
up at what point is it reasonable to
sell or do you hold it forever you know
but but to come up with a plan in
advance because if you don't have a plan
you know one of my favorite quotes is a
mike tyson quote i don't know if you
have told you this one already um
where he says uh you know everyone has a
plan in boxing till they get a punch in
the face you know and it's the same
thing in investing right where people
you know they they think they'll get
into the stock market and they'll be
really rational and and they have great
ideas and then you know the minute it
either falls too much or rises too much
their emotions take control of them and
it's gone you know yeah yeah yeah that's
absolutely true
sp speaking of emotions getting the best
of us um
meme coins i've just been dying inside
watching that all uh that that whole
facade go up listen like sheba coin all
the floky listen i think personally it's
ridiculous speculation bubble i've been
very clear about that i think it's
basically a ponzi scheme but i heard a
large youtuber the other day is finance
youtuber telling me over the phone like
not for an audience he just goes look i
legit think
meme coins have inherent value i think
the fact they draw attention gets the
money that money will then turn into
utility somewhere down the road sort of
argument like
we'll just we'll sell you a plane and
then we'll get a lot of money and then
we'll build the plane with the money we
raise basically uh what do you think
about that the problem is you could make
that argument about anything you know
like to say that there's inherent value
to something that's
firstly like it's very difficult to say
anything that doesn't have cash flows
has inherent value right like it's just
it's just a thing you know it's kind of
the same argument can be made about any
sort of collectible like art like uh
you know you name it old stamps things
like that and so yes there there
possibly is something to the idea that
if something sort of have has had value
for a long time and there's a big
community that believes in it that that
it could possibly hold on but i'm not
sure that that relates to like you know
the deal
the funny one over the weekend was the
omega cryptocurrency you know i guess
there was one named that anyhow because
it's a greek letter and as soon as it
was announced that there was a new
variant of the virus people went out and
bought the cryptocurrency that has the
same name as the virus unbelievable how
much did it go up i i believe 900 with
the thing i saw you know but but the
funny thing is there's actually kind of
a long history of this in markets um a
guy i used to work with had done all
sorts of studies on this and you know
whenever there was like good news in
we'll say the tech sector every stock
would sort of micro or something like
that in its name would go up and there's
even things where
stocks that have ticker symbols that
sound like um the ticker symbol of the
company that has good news will go up
you know and in truth you could build a
system to invest based you know to make
money to trade based upon that but it's
not uh you know if it works it works and
i feel you know you can do what you
think works but in terms of like for
someone to put their money in something
as a long-term store of value i really
don't think that like
you know sort of a coin that's tied to
an internet joke has any
long-term uh you know investment
potential
wow the memers are gonna be very upset
with you about that the the reddit
memers not happy uh okay speaking of
reddit let's talk about bitcoin okay
uh michael saylor is a famous ceo i
don't know if you know that is he's gone
a hundred percent
basically a hundred percent into bitcoin
well he was a big guy in the dot-com
bubble as well and now he's back with
with the crypto uh
well we'll get to that yeah he's he's
famous now for claiming that bitcoin
will
basically do anything for you it'll make
you immortal it'll save the world and
also by the way make everyone rich uh
and incidentally make him rich too which
is a nice side effect uh what do you
think what do you think of that strategy
of all in it's you know we always hear
diversify diversify or diversify here's
a guy
he's putting his entire reputation on
one coin
you know it slightly depends on what you
want to do like if you work nothing and
you walk into a casino you should
probably take the riskiest highest
return bet and odds are you'll you'll
you'll probably walk out with nothing
but there's a small chance that you'll
walk away with a fortune right and
that's what that type of bet is so if
you've got like a hundred bucks and and
you're retiring in three years time you
know you've no savings you might need to
just roll the dice like as as
inappropriate as that is as investment
advice but for most people like the way
people really grow their wealth and i've
seen this with you know
hundreds of people like it's
most people i see who really grow their
wealth and who sort of reach a
retirement age with with uh you know a
large excessive wealth tend to do it
slow and steady like we're just sensible
investments that work like they you know
investing in in
good businesses good ideas you know like
yes you can you can go crazy the
question is even if you do
make a fortune on a crazy bed do you
have the good sense then to realize that
you just got lucky and now do sensible
things afterwards and the problem is not
a lot of people do
yeah exactly exactly so i want to talk
about financial advice youtubers i'll
say slash influencers there's been a lot
of talk about the hashtag not financial
advice movement you know people will
give you financial advice but then in a
weird get out of jail free card they
will just say not financial advice and
it absolves them of all responsibility
what do you think about that people
giving out stock picks
sort of more blatantly or
i don't know cavalierly than ever it's
funny to me it's just it's not something
i would do and it's not something that
really anyone i know as a professional
would do simply because different people
have different risk appetites and so on
you know and so if if someone it's kind
of like being a doctor and going on
youtube and saying like this medicine
will fix everything that's wrong with
you it's like well you know normally
before writing a prescription you ask a
patient the uh you know to describe
their symptoms you know while the
problem with a youtuber telling you what
you should buy is the is that they don't
know your financial situation your goals
anything and also it's rather
questionable to me like a lot of the
financial youtubers i've seen are sort
of
real estate agents who've worked out
that you can give financial advice on
the internet and it's not obvious to me
that they're very knowledgeable but i i
just i wouldn't want to take
responsibility for someone's losses like
if i
announced on my channel that there's
this stock that you should definitely
buy
the the problem with that is like if it
goes horribly wrong that person can't
come to me and say patrick you you you
put me in this thing i i'd say oh i
didn't you know and and equally if it
goes really well will will they stick to
my channel for me to announce that it's
now time to get out of it you know it
doesn't to me that's not how financial
advice works and i'd rather see people
learn so that they can give themselves
financial advice like if you educate
yourself if you read good books on the
topic and if you study up on it and
learn how professionals look at the
market you can then do your own analysis
and then of course you're relying on
yourself you know you you you know why
you made the investment and so you
equally know when it might be time to
sell for a variety of reasons and to me
that's much more value-added than you
know there's a lot of youtubers and
they're like here's my portfolio this is
what i bought this is how much i made it
to me like i you know i they they can do
what they want but it's just not obvious
to me that that's value added for for a
viewer
now pivoting a bit from that and this is
sort of one of the final questions i
want to ask you
it does feel it does appear to me that
the game
is rigged okay and so my question is
sort of so now what so something i find
in crypto a lot is that the influencers
and the developers are often
in on it they sort of collude marketing
deals they have private sales that
exclude the average investor they always
just sort of know things that the
average investor does not and sometimes
they include to scam obviously but most
of the time they just have more
information so the game is the game is
tilted and this isn't new though this is
sort of always been the case in
traditional markets as well
of asymmetric knowledge what would you
tell investors who are looking at the
market they see that but the answer
doesn't seem to me to be to just throw
up your hands and go i guess i'll never
invest in anything because i i you know
the game is rigged i don't think that's
a good answer what would you tell the
people who sort of realized that
you know the the game isn't as rigged as
people think the problem when you look
at things like crypto it's like looking
at you know i think uh the head of the
sec is described as the wild west and in
many ways it's kind of like the most
extreme emerging market that there is
you know um now good example actually in
the united states in the in the 1920s
pre the 1929 crash there was a huge uh
you know eruption of uh interest in the
stock market and stock values went up
and it was uh you know in many ways a
golden age for investors but equally a
golden age for fraudsters where people
like charles ponzi and so on appeared
around that time
with this uh
with that growth it was during a time in
which uh big companies didn't give you
any accounts right like so they'd they'd
issue stock in the company partial
ownership in the company they wouldn't
tell you any accounting any earnings any
detail and so people really just
invested based on kind of gut feeling
and rumors they heard and of course the
rumors were all spread by uh you know
people trying to try to pump the stock
so it all ended horribly in 1929 and
that's when a lot of securities
regulation came in you know all of the
the regulation that the meaningful
regulation came in in the early 1930s
that basically said that companies
can't lie about stuff and they have to
issue us a certain amount of detailed
information it might need to be audited
and so on interestingly you look around
the world and in many emerging markets
you'll find similar situations to the
united states in the in the 1920s and so
you look in those countries and you
speak to people like you know i've made
a series of videos on ever grant the
chinese company and all chinese people
just invest in real estate okay it's the
only thing they invest in and the reason
is because they don't trust any of the
other stuff and it's because of this
sort of questionable accounting and so
on now the great thing about the united
states is actually it's one of the
better regulated markets in the world
and so actually you do
get a pretty fair shake when you invest
in american uh you know kind of blue
chip stocks in the united states so not
penny stocks but like kind of any
respectable big you know exchange traded
stock you can invest in is
you know they are forced by law to to
release honest information on a
quarterly basis and so on and this is a
good thing and so the problem now is
that i think a lot of people look at
things like they look at the world of
cryptocurrencies
and they think that they get the same
protections that they get in in the u.s
stock market and it's like look you
don't get those same protections in a
foreign stock market not to mind in
cryptocurrencies you know logan paul
doesn't care about you and your savings
you know no don't tell me that
i thought logan cared what
i know it's it's amazing that a youtube
prankster isn't uh isn't providing the
the best financial advice ever crazy
it's crazy listen i i do have to
actually ask like okay that that is a
fair point and i'm i'm glad you balanced
that uh that idea out however we do see
and i gotta bring it up look we've seen
a lot of these stock these uh
these nancy pelosi types these uh the i
think tom cotton cotton might be another
one they're just a bunch of
senators who i think it was like over 50
who just this year
allegedly have broken the stock act okay
which is the insider trading law
and it doesn't appear that any of them
are gonna face any kind of problems and
they all seem to be amazing investors
right out of the gate having never been
really been into finance before it just
seems this amazing thing what do you
think about that like should i just copy
i'm just starting to think i should copy
uh
i think it's pelosi's husband who trades
it's not actually her it's it's her
husband it's just this amazing
amazing market i don't know what you'd
call it timer uh profit so yeah what do
you think about that you know that is a
problem but it's something that's kind
of it has been dealt with and they're
passing new regulation about that so
it was actually up until only very
recently i forget what year it actually
was not against the law for them to
trade on the information they had that
related to them passing laws because
insider information meant
information from inside a company rather
this was sort of outside information
that they gathered within their their
careers so of course there have been
laws and there are more laws coming to
to reduce that but it um you know
obviously the thing i don't like about
that is it causes people to lose faith
in investing and i i really do think you
know if you look at the long term
returns of the stock market it really is
the the best thing to do with your
savings like it outperforms real estate
it outperforms bonds there's you know
it's a really good place for people to
put their long-term savings for
retirement and of course then when you
see these scandals the problem is that
people do lose faith and they they
decide to make maybe sub-optimal
decisions because they they don't want
to be scammed um
go ahead yeah oh no yeah no i'm chomping
at the bit here because you just you
just offended a lot of tick-tockers okay
they're upset at you because actually a
lot of people say look the stock market
that's for that's for boomers who don't
understand the power of flipping houses
or uh you know all these real estate
schemes i think real estate's fine i
mean real estate you can make money with
real estate but i didn't i don't have
good data on you know real estate versus
stock investing do you do you have
something to tell us there i didn't well
i mean there's lots you you know you
could even just google this and you'll
find it like this i i studied with a guy
called elroy jimson in london who
created a time series of sort of almost
every asset in the world like
collectibles um
real estate bonds stocks uh every
country in the world and you're able to
look at the you know over 100 years of
returns data on that and you really see
that just the reason that a a stock
investment should earn more than a real
estate investment is just simply that a
stock that you buy it's actually a
business like you're investing in a
business and they're creating goods and
services and selling them at a profit
and that profit then goes to the owners
of the business which is the
shareholders with real estate in
particular if it's a home you live in
you're really just getting price
appreciation which is kind of driven by
dynamics like increase in population or
uh or really just inflation you know and
a lot of the return you'll see is is
tight inflation and then you've got
other things like as interest rates come
down home prices tend to go up just
because people tend to buy them with
borrowed money and so the lower the
interest rates are the cheaper you can
borrow the more money you can borrow for
a given cash flow so you can spend more
on a house so therefore you see the
overall house stock in a country
increase in value as rates go down but
of course we're now possibly at a low of
interest rates and that that's a trade
that's worked since 19 i think it's like
1982 when interest rates started falling
and have continued to fall since so you
know you you kind of need to understand
the drivers of the different asset
classes in order to to decide how you
might invest based upon like how you
view the economy at a given point in
time that's an amazing answer i
i've learned so much here today patrick
thank you so much for giving us the
stock market secrets and especially that
last answer uh was incredibly insightful
for understanding why real estate
appreciates over time what stocks
appreciate over time if people want to
find you they can find you at patrick
boyle the youtube channel is that right
yes yeah that's kind of my main
sort of communication tool to the world
so yeah guys go subscribe to him he puts
out amazing analysis all the time i love
to have him on the channel yeah
amazing i'm glad we got the chance to do
this thank you for having me on all
right hope you guys learned something be
safe out there thanks for watching see
you in the next
you one relate this part of the story
don't just pan away